FHIR resources have a logical identity or ID that is
unique among all resources of the same type on each FHIR server.
Just to be clear,
the patient resource ID will usually be different on each FHIR server,
so it cannot establish patient identity across servers.
However, there is a discussion of the use of FHIR for
a master patient index on the patient resource page of the FHIR website.
And there is even this value set to indicate the quality of a patient query match.
I mention this as much as anything to show you how rich the FHIR standard is
becoming and to urge you to explore it further.
Here, further down in the allergy resource we've been exploring,
you see references by ID to the patient,
"example" who has this allergy as well as to the practitioner,
"13" who recorded it.
These references can be absolute or relative.
Once assigned, the identity is never changed.
However, a copy of that resource on
another server might not be able to retain the same logical identity.
As shown here via these references,
FHIR resources create a network of information.
The unique identifier of a resource instance is
an absolute URI constructed from the server base address,
the resource type, and the logical ID.
When the literal identity is an HTTP address,
this address can generally retrieve or manipulate the resource,
as I illustrate here using the public HAPI, H-A-P-I, FHIR server.
Here are the three parts of the URL.
The server base address of fhirtest.uhn.ca,
the resource type of
baseDstu2/Patient that combines the resource type with the version of FHIR,
and the resource ID of 3535.
Finally, here you see that as it should,
the internal reference to the FHIR ID matches the one in the URL.
You should easily be able to do the same
using the Georgia Tech or any public FHIR service.
Simply search for a resource and then note
its literal URL and the three parts that make it up.
Before moving on, note the use of DSTU in the URL we just looked at.
As I said earlier,
you're likely to run into this,
even though the preferred term is now STU.
They are equivalent.
Note that implementation should not assume that
the identity of a resource is always resolvable to a literal server.
It may be temporarily unavailable or may not be available by policy,
such as firewalls or in some cases it may not actually exist,
such as the use of resources outside of a RESTful environment.
Logical ID literal references are case sensitive.
They can be up to 64 characters long and
contain any combination of upper and lower case ASCII characters,
numerals, dashes, and periods,
as illustrated by the patient ID of "example" we saw earlier.
I have posted a link to a video that demonstrates
the use of clinFHIR to create FHIR resources.
ClinFHIR is an excellent open public comprehensive FHIR resource created by David Hay,
a leader in the FHIR community.
I strongly recommend you explore it.